welcome
to
my
technically first ever playthrough
of dark souls 2. i've tried to play this
game before
i played dark souls 3 first then i
played dark souls 1 then i played
bloodborne and then
i tried dark souls 2 and i didn't like
it i i think i tried it for maybe 15
minutes
five years ago i don't remember
relatively anything about this game i
know you hate it but i don't know enough
about the game to hate it and this game
has a very bad reputation in the souls
community kind of or being the worst in
the series it's usually at the bottom of
everybody's list in terms of the souls
games but i've never really never truly
played it so i'm gonna play it for the
first time and actually give it an
opinion it's not a good sign that i
played it five years ago and just like
stopped playing it completely i've heard
the dlc of the game is actually the best
part but let's start a new game and
let's get to it
ooh a cutscene this looks like elden
ring kinda
we're in the miss wood
everything who is that
oh i see are we going like deeper in the
like the effects of how being branded
with the dark sign like affects the
person that's kind of cool
i've never really thought of it that way
you know i believe
this looks awesome
wow
okay are these like the finger maidens
are these fire keepers
who are these people
he's kind of creepy this cinematic's
beautiful
just want to say this is great
has the most rpg elements of of all the
souls games okay
this is the best part of the game is the
cinematic metal
okay
why would you step in there my guy
oh
cool
because he's just cursed he's just
walking
like
yeah he's he's not even in his right
frame of mind interesting how would you
rate the souls games
um dark souls 3 is my favorite i think
uh it's between dark souls 3 or
bloodborne then sakiro
or not sakiro then elden ring then
sikiro dark souls 1 dark souls 2. i've
never finished this game i've may have i
think i've played like 20 minutes of it
five years ago so i'm trying to i want
to play it i really want to get a taste
of like i want the full experience of
this game good or bad that's what i'm
going for like even if i don't like it
that's fine things betwixt is that like
the lands between the things betwixt
isn't that what that means
wow this is pretty
oh i have half health already it's just
like demon souls uh and i haven't
finished demon souls yet i'm working on
it
i just tried to jump this is gonna be
bad why would it kill you if i like this
game all right it's not gonna be that
bad it's gonna be fine it's a game we're
gonna get through it who are these
people
they're retired fire keepers
oh is that why they're blind they look
blind
like uh
their eyes are faded out you'll go
hollow yeah
why are they so bitter
one thing i do like about this game is
the music i think the music's really
good i've used it in a ton of videos
you know your own name
they're so mean
i swear i heard that somewhere that
cleric is the best class
because you can use magic and it's like
it's
mace yeah it looks like a mace at the
beginning it's pretty good depends on
your build so it doesn't matter right
okay yeah i've heard adaptability has to
do with iframes right and you're dodging
like your dodge rolls
and it's pretty important
from what i've heard i want to say
that the fire keepers acting like this
seems really out of character
i never took them as bitter
bitter beans you know what i mean i
don't know that seems off so the iframe
thing is the dumbest thing you've ever
heard in your life i mean it does seem
kind of weird is this like an
a fire keeper in training can i talk to
you
all right you're a [ __ ] i'm out
she just laughs at me all right
whatever
so i just don't get shoes is that how
this works just no shoes
oh that's pretty
that's gor oh my god this is beautiful
yeah i don't remember this at all
wow
some really good water effects hey
there's the music
i use this music all the time is this
like this is the hub area yep got it
it's a big hub area
oh hello
who's this
[Music]
this is really cool
is this my fire keeper
oh an estes flash
see the king he who made drangleic what
it once was
he who peered at the essence of the soul
king
king vendrick
you may level up by the power of the
emerald herald did the curse just like
make us walk here
is that like the scene where we just
fell
into the
the whirlpool or whatever when do you
expect elden ring dlc to be announced i
would be very surprised if they
announced dlc this year i think it'll be
next year i really do i i would be very
surprised obviously very happy but very
surprised if they do it uh any earlier
than that i like how i can move
with the menu that's kind of cool
what what's the fall damage like in this
game don't mess with it all right i i
don't think i want to go down there yet
a kitty
i can talk to the cat
oh undead are we oh is this the cat from
dark souls one not exactly the time to
be chatting i had the really wide face
dark souls 2 is not a bad game i'll die
in this hill
um i keep hearing it's pretty bad man
but we'll see we'll see is this mace i
have okay
it seemed to do decent damage to those
tutorial people that i saw
holy [ __ ]
heidi's tower of flame hello are you
mean okay you don't want to hurt me so i
won't hurt you
okay like this is really pretty for a
game what is this 2015 this is really
really good like uh visually neat oh
that is a big boy
i've seen people finish the game with
this mace all right bet all right all
right what do you got
okay
decent damage oh okay i didn't expect
the swipe to hit me
okay another checkpoint
excellent
dog
okay i'm dead how does a life gem work
extremely slow healing got it
oh god
nice achievement this is dark souls here
we are on one of them he swung his thing
and then like the very end of it hit me
and it still hit me for as much damage
that seems kind of weird okay
oh god
this is going to drop me in the water
uh that seems helpful i guess all right
hold on the lever iframes
you can't hit me
hey how far do they like want to go
after me
the people behind me why do you want to
fight me now man you were like chilling
it's a [ __ ] dragon up here what the
hell okay
you said they relentlessly go after me
all i want are my souls
that i have obtained so far that's all i
want leave me be i jump for some reason
all right i gotta run
yeah my souls are five feet closer i'm
gonna run for the dragon as well i'm
just gonna i'm gonna book it right at
the dragon
and and now my souls are in a worse spot
i'm i am not already frustrated that's
not happening like the rising tension in
my heart right now i'm gonna put it back
down and i'm just not gonna go up there
that's it that's all i'm gonna do i'm
just not gonna go up there it's fine
leave me alone leave me alone leave me
alone
i'm going in here i don't know what's in
here but we're going in here
a boss all right sick
not a fan of that
okay okay
beach
i got greedy i got greedy i got greedy
wow
just a gamer out here
you're bad you're bad at the game i'm
even gonna live gym right in front of
you keep running in a weird circle man
you'll do you so much good
oh now you're holding it up you're kind
of bad at the game you're bad at this
oh
oh
one more
i almost threw
for content
first try that boss is easy
i beat the boss
leave me alone holy sh leave me alone
are you kidding me
imagine like this your first souls game
and that happens like you beat a boss
and then the guy just come and bops you
in the face are you from these parts no
upgrade estes flask what do i need for
that give estes flash shard
you don't have any then why would you
even give me the option to do that you
forehead adp for iframes most important
stat get it at least at a good level to
get it out of the way i'd say okay it's
this one right a a tone a t i don't know
i don't know what atn means let's get
that to 18. [ __ ] it wait did i do the
wrong one no
[ __ ] no
i thought
i'm dyslexic i'm literally dyslexic my
adp is four
man oh my bad my bad all right whatever
it's fine well we'll figure it out we're
just putting we're putting [ __ ] out
there you know i mean where does this go
down
down what would you say the best souls
game is i think it depends on who you
are it's either dark souls 3 or
bloodborne for me elden ring is great
for what it is it's just not my favorite
souls game nah bro nope that's one of
the oh
man came out of nowhere to scare the
piss out of me is there a lot of
bonfires in this game i feel like
there's a lot so far get annihilated
you're bad arrow coming in right now
i freaking knew it and still got hit
it's right in my forehead
this guy's fighting like a pirate
oh
hey i like the backstab animations
yo holy [ __ ]
leave me be you guys weren't kidding
when they just go after you here okay
there's a lot of mobs in this game
holy
oh [ __ ] there's literally nothing in
here
get on all of you
i wish there was a trap or something
is there any point in running in this
game like running away because they're
always just gonna track you down you
skip the first real area of the game and
returning that place later would make it
too easy but maybe go there first
okay uh where where was i supposed to go
from the bonfire look around there's a
tunnel here
oh damn that boy thick
bro
like i
i literally got distracted by the random
guy coming to just join the fight this
game tries to be non-linear like dark
souls 1 but it does not quite succeed i
haven't really noticed that yet it seems
like there's just a bunch of branching
pads
from majula
which
is like dark souls 1. why the hell would
i want a broken straight sword
why do they get always give me a broken
straight sword in these games
okay that seems bad so i'm not going to
go in there
excellent both paths are bad i knew you
were back here
there's another one
my god oh my god
just stop i don't know why i'm i'm
running away because it's not gonna help
why does everybody laugh at me okay what
the [ __ ]
it's a turtle
can i get up please
bye
you're bad at the game what did you just
throw at me bro
uh-huh ball damage nigh okay that kind
of hurt me the tiniest little bit
are these all manned
yep
bro
bro help me bro
bro
homie don't want to help huh come on
this guy don't give a [ __ ] hey traveling
all alone in these treacherous times
didn't have to but you know you could
have helped nah i've played enough of
these games to know when what's a trap
and what's not for the most part oh cool
is this a sword yeah that's a hand and
this is a sword
oh oh oh oh i see
uh-huh
oh yeah
i i'm getting the vibe that what they
did to make this game hard was to just
throw a bunch of mobs at you because we
one shot at the first boss we came
across but yet i'm dying to like not
even getting hit by random ass mobs yes
that's that's the vibe i'm getting right
now you know that may not be completely
true but
are you [ __ ] kidding me a man
straight up climbed up here
i wouldn't got hit by that if that guy
wasn't here okay this guy's kind of dope
though
really strong i'm learning i'm learning
apparently i was wrong about that
[Music]
i was doing so good and it all just
unraveled yeah the only difficulty in
this game is just the mob
the areas that they put mobs in
well
did you do this
oh i'm sorry
i was just
daydreaming
are you kidding me
my name is kale hi kale this guy is
really bent over here
why cartography you
i i didn't ask
questions i really didn't ask my guy all
right
that's great all right i'll talk to him
more then you are fascinated by maps
just like me i didn't say that we'll
have we'll have map jackets it'll be a
really cool club everyone will want to
join our club are two barrels enough
never [ __ ] mind i'll get the bombs
from the merchant that's that's the vibe
i'm getting with this game right now the
mob placement is just there to piss you
off
well maybe i'm just bad at the game
right
maybe i'm just [ __ ] trash
[Music]
wait okay i guess that's better that's
that's fine this is fine it's not much
of a shortcut but i will take it that
saved me about five minutes of headache
that's great i love that for me
why are you guarding one door
who who are you
all right
sit some some guy with the
with a pokey stick is just placed right
there little pokey stick haven't seen a
single enemy like that definitely
getting frustrated man
uh hey it's that guy they were beating
up upstairs all right second boss
is this gonna suck
the last giant
he's not super
wrong
but he will smack me in the face i see
you can't did he just rip his arm off
theme's not good for you
nice jump back my guy
guys the bosses in this game are a joke
so far i'm only dying to dumbly like
really hard placed mobs that's it i
don't know it's a level this is this is
a lot my endurance is so low i'm i'm
tuning that up a bit
my stamina seems just dog [ __ ] yeah i
have your key my guy and you are
uh
uh
another useless traveler i literally got
you the key so you can do your job but
i'm useless i'll be around if you break
it back
shut the f this guy is a troll man
not bad
excellent
easy get out of my face you suck at this
game
produce the symbol of the king the [ __ ]
does that mean another path i don't know
what to do with we'll come back to that
i suppose this game is very different
that's that's the vibe i'm getting so
far
it is nothing like dark souls 1 it is
nothing like dark souls 3 nothing like
dark souls 3.
it's just kind of it's just weird so i'm
trying to accept it for what it is you
know i'm saying
like i'm trying to i'm trying to see it
from a different light but when you call
a game dark souls 2 i'm gonna assume
it's like dark souls right
and that right there guys is some 2006
fire effects right there i won't lie
this game's graphics are pretty uh like
majula was beautiful
it really was but then like the rest of
the textures and in some spots like this
is okay but when i look a bit closer i'm
like
yeah the game i would say the game looks
worse than dark souls 1 at least in my
opinion graphically it does look worse
dark souls 1 was difficult by design not
like by just placing mobs in annoying
[ __ ] areas i like the menu the menu's
cool
i will say that
the the menuing and like your character
being on the far right side while you're
going through it looks really nice and
it feels clean uh is there like more to
explore in this area
now
like why not just bend me over and peg
my [ __ ] no i don't know what the
pursuer is where's the pursuer all right
what's in here
boss fight
yes hey it's that guy yep there he is
i tried to fight him earlier but i
almost killed him
oh [ __ ]
is that the crow from dark souls one
that hurt
that's a use
well i can't use them anymore
okay i feel like i'm doing good
stamina management
excellent
oh that would have been cringe if that
killed me dude
i haven't died to a boss just saying
these bosses are a joke dude gg easy no
re okay so right here
water
the background the atmosphere here
chef's kiss beautiful
but like some other areas just look like
total dog [ __ ] like poopoo dongwata
[Music]
you